every bit of that Playa is full of
mercury arsenic selenium it's full of it
the largest impact of course will be
dust the cost of not do anything could
be in the tens of billions of dollars we
are screwed because 20 years ago not
enough people were thinking 20 years
ahead
little by little the Salton Sea is
disappearing California's largest inland
body of water used to cover where I'm
standing but right now it's receded so
far behind me that I can barely see it
and disaster looms on the horizon toxic
dust is getting kicked up and the
communities nearby are suffering from
alarming rates of asthma and kids are
some of the most vulnerable
you let that feed die we're gonna die
with it
this is not a joke this area already
looks like Mad Max meets Timothy Leary
gutted communities burping mounds of mud
and piles of dead fish along the beaches
but it didn't always look this bad in
1905 and 1906 the Salton Sea was created
by accident when the banks of the
Colorado River broke and flooded it at
the time people thought that the lake
was just going evaporate and disappear
but what ended up happening was that it
was fed by water like this that was
runoff from farms in the nearby area
back then water was so plentiful it
seemed like a good idea to turn a desert
into farmland today farmers still flood
their fields and agriculture has grown
into a billion dollar a year industry
the water also drew people it's hard to
imagine now but in the 50s and 60s the
sea drew more people than Yosemite
including Hollywood glitterati
now the nearby towns have been whittled
down to diehard locals and the curious
charter boats for fishing water-ski just
hanging out and having fun and it's a
beautiful beautiful area my first
husband and I were on our honeymoon
there was like seven restaurants and
drinking establishments on that on the
beach it was beautiful this was a really
fun place to be if I brought my wife on
our honeymoon here she'd divorce me yeah
well it probably it looks a lot
different now oh it's extremely
different the good times could only last
so long as Southern California grew so
did demand for water from the Colorado
River which sustains cities throughout
the Southwest as well as farming here in
the Imperial Valley these farms pull
more water than anyone else and the
city's wanted a bigger cut
in 2003 San Diego agreed to pay these
farmers millions for their water the
deal also required the state to come up
with a plan to save the Salton Sea
problem is they haven't and in 2017 the
tap to the sea will shut off we don't
have the enclose of water that we had
before I think it is a dire moment with
time running out in mid-2015 Governor
Jerry Brown appointed this man Bruce
Wilcox to find a solution California
could afford everyone wanted the perfect
solution to the Salton Sea and there
isn't one living close to the Salton Sea
if nothing is done if no management is
implemented is gonna be a tough deal and
it's gonna get worse as the sea declines
not to play the blame game but was the
state doing enough before I don't think
anybody was doing enough before yeah
including the state
when the wind blows it picks up fine
dust like this from the top of the
exposed playa and many worried that
that's why the rate of asthma here in
the area is three times higher than
anywhere else in the state experts fear
that one hundred square miles of Playa
or dry lakebed could be exposed within a
decade in 2014 local students headed to
the state capital to urge lawmakers to
take action my little brother has asthma
but the only thing I can do is hold it
air quality gets better if it dries up
it will be like this toxic waste line
that's all it'll be it's life or death
hospitalization rates are very very high
actually compared to the rest of
California and you know there's a
connection that when the wind starts
flowing or it is dust in the air and it
gets will come in suffering with asthma
the communities around the Salton Sea
are primarily Hispanic working-class
families largely tied to farming
it's that the right of asthma it seems
I'm carry more than more inhalers every
year it's really bad and it seems to
have gotten worse it's like there's less
oxygen and I could dust don't like lock
up my nostrils I can hardly breathe
the particulate matter in the air is
going to increase drastically so that
exposed Playa also has chemicals like
arsenic selenium and mercury are those
things that will also potentially have
public health impacts definitely because
those are things that are linked with
neurological problems with immune
suppression problems with cancers as you
can see there's a string a row here of
just dead fish dozens and dozens of fish
it ended up here on the shores it's
something you see all along the edges of
the Salton Sea
so the Salton Sea is a terminal Lake
there's no exit water itself evaporates
but water brings with it a lot of salts
and other contaminants so over time it's
become increasingly salty the rising
salinity is killing off the fish and
that starts a dangerous domino effect
for over 400 species of migrating birds
who would normally stop here those birds
are gonna have to go somewhere else the
challenge however is that we've dried up
most of the wetlands in the state of
California so there's not too many other
places for them to go where do you
recommend we go is there is there a
fairly safe but how do you save a
shrinking sea when there's not enough
water to go around I cross the border
into Mexico
with a group of activists who want to
bring water back to the Salton Sea by
connecting it with the Sea of Cortez
they're looking for possible routes this
is the Laguna Salada it's a dry lakebed
in Mexico and it's covered in this fine
dust
it's what the Salton Sea looked like
before 1905 and some activists fear that
if the state of California doesn't act
fast
then the Salton Sea could look like this
again and so they've proposed a bold
plan that would take water from the Sea
of Cortez and channel it across this dry
lakebed and send it all the way down
into the Salton Sea
[Music]
the CDC plan how long is that going to
take to become a reality if I had
everybody say go right now and take five
years and for what costs the total cost
right now are about 90 billion 90
billion dollars yeah
but the money is there where's the money
I can't tell you that but I can tell you
the money's here I have lots of lenders
I have lots of people who are willing to
participate Dutch are willing to
participate and finance all the green
houses in agriculture so the Dutch close
to Rica there's people there willing to
finance all the solar this is hard to
believe but when you hear yourself
explain this project does it sound
realistic to you yeah it does but then
I'm looking at it from a different side
of the window
[Music]
I can't help but think this is what it
must have felt like to settle the West
to look out at a desert and see so much
potential it was an era when no
infrastructure project was too big or
unreasonable it was a time for romantics
for dreaming big but today things are
much more complicated the reality is
that the future of the Salton Sea will
probably be decided here somewhere much
less romantic state assemblyman john
monoid has proposed a very
different-looking plan that seems
perfectly tailored for budget weary
politicians in Sacramento we've got a
consensus building around a plan that
basically creates a small body of water
down here runs water along the edge the
plan promises to address some of the
most pressing problems it would create
habitats for wildlife and bring tourist
dollars back to the region but know it
also says it will keep down the dust
problem is no one's sure exactly how
that will work so you're confident there
with this Swift plan that's not going to
be an issue well let me say that when we
have the full build-out we will have a
very comprehensive plan and just to be
clear your your district is up here
right and the wind blows that way
predominantly yeah also unknown is when
any of this will get approved funded and
ultimately finished
maybe 2020 maybe 2019 maybe 2025 there's
a lot of questions out there but no its
plan has political momentum but with all
these questions it doesn't feel like a
real solution for the unfolding disaster
in the Imperial Valley we've already
seen a migration from the Salton Sea
Bombay Beach desert Shores
it used to be just lively places when
the water goes the migration will begin
but that's not always an option plenty
of people here tell me they can't afford
to move or they don't want to leave
their homes for years into California's
historic drought communities all over
the state are desperate for water and
what's happening here around the Salton
Sea could be an alarming premonition of
what
to come
[Music]
you